The ultimate fighter.
Correct.
He really couldn't train properly
with it. Yeah, that's, that's,
it's going to be a different animal in
the future when people aren't worried as
much about permanent damage.
Right.
I hope I need it because I
do a lot of permanent damage.
Yeah. The gym most damaged
today's permanent damage.
Wild excursions. I go on.
Tell me about the cave dot.
You want to learn about cave diving.
Kay.
So first of all, Katie wants
to take you, she takes you,
so you learn about all these
different rules of the water and of the
nitrogen levels that you're taking into
your body. Um, any of the cave
diving is about five years.
And I got my certification in high
school and I am a super cave diver man.
I love it. I love it. I love, I love
diving. I love everything about diving.
I love Shipt diving. Um, so no
days, caves, you name it. I love it.
So we were in Cozumel a
couple weeks ago and uh,
one of my old,
you could almost call him instructor.
He's taught me a lot of what
I know about diving today.
We a dove three or four days and some
buddies of mine that were down and uh,
goes and Mel just went through. Some ships
went through, some k are, uh, like, um,
it's the coral reef just
playing around down with them.
And then we go and do a
s a a serious die always.
He's getting a little bit older. His
mind is still very, very, very sharp.
But his motor skills don't keep up
with it much anymore. Right. And in,
in, in cave diving, it, uh, it's
very necessity that you need.
So we jumped in this cave.
Let's rewind to 20 minutes.
I just kissed my girl and my
new baby and she's like, don't,
I don't really want you to go like right.
I don't,
he just, I don't want to say his
name, but the guy you're going with,
like I'm worried. I said, what
are you worried about? I said,
I'm coming home. Come. This is what
I come home every time coming home.
Fuck. I Dunno. So I pick up
another, I order another,
um, cylinder of air just
for x. So I have to,
originally I'm going with order another
cylinder air. Just, I told her just for,
just for, just to fucking had it, right.
No one's ever died because they
have too much air in cave diving,
you dive in third, so if we have
300 PSI, we'll do a thousand psi.
N would do a thousand psi out and we
have a thousand psi in case something
fucking happens. Also in cage
dive in, they have lines.
You run these in a cave.
The law already have a line running.
A bunch of guys like me, tech divers
have gone into caves to cover them.
They mapped them,
they named him and they put put lines
so you can follow them in case something
happens. Right. Get in and get out
lines and lines and none of the lines
really connect Schaeffer like the main
lines. We'll have like three
or four main lines down.
Big channels of the cave
because caves are huge. Right?
From an intern to the main line.
Usually no one has a cave. You have to,
you have to make it.
It was called a jump.
You have to make your own own line
because they just don't want someone
listening on deer today to go find a cave,
jump in and swim down and be able to
get in and out and get lost in there.
Now also, we have a Thailand incident.
We're looking to want him to say people.
So we make a jump tie off.
You put these direction arrows down.
Um, they're called cookies, right?
Pointing out towards the direction out
of the cave is that way if something
happens, you come out, when you
make a jump, you take your light,
you wrap it around your neck, and then
you have two hands that work on the line.
The Guy I was with didn't
follow some of our rules.
And in cave diving,
it's kind of an unwritten fact
that you only worry about you.
I'm coming home, right? I'm
fucking staying alive. So Joe,
you mean I were Dave diving.
If something were to happen,
I'm not going in there to get you.
No reason for two of us die
when only ones in there can die.
So he tries to tie off his points.
He fucking hits the roof of the cave,
kicks his feet,
spins analysis in this line
that's supposed to be tied off,
which is our fucking lifeline
is now wrapped around him.
So I swim over to them and I try to help
him unhook this line and he goes into
panic and panic kills everybody involved.
Everybody involved dies with panic.
And that's something that
I can't express enough.
So he starts fucking freaking out, hitting
the roof, spinning silk fucking over.
And I just back out,
take about four or five
big strong steps back
when I grab a hold of the main line.
Now it's silting out.
Now when I say something silting out,
there's all this like sediment,
the ends on the bottom of, of these caves.
And you were like a little tiny room.
So if you kick your fin hard,
it kicks up like dark dust,
mud, sediment, silt. You can't
fucking see anything, blacks it out.
So I back out of the silt.
I grabbed the line and I see him in
there fucking freaking and panicking,
spinning and rolling around and getting
all caught up in this and this line.
And I'm like, fuck, I just stay calm.
This was the exit. I know where it is
cause I know where I am. There's the exit.
He was making a jump to go down
another tunnel. There he is.
Now what I just tell you about the
rule that someone comes home, right?
I broke the rule and I went in to
get him. I said, Fuck God down.
So I let go of the line
and I go into get him because there's
light fucking is off now and I'm thinking,
God damn, he spun up in this line.
Is Lights off? Did he drop his ray?
He later is he had air.
Is he okay? Soon as I go,
the sill fucking lose everything man.
Lose my way. Where I am, my up, my down.
I don't know where I am.
A fucking panicky now I'm panicking.
Fucking freaking out more than
any I've ever breathing hard bang.
Hit My head on the fucking ceiling and
I just closed my eyes and I'm like,
God dammit Kelly, calm the fuck down.
Calm the fuck down. Calm the fuck down.
Breathe.
Can't even see my hands in front of me.
I have two watches on their glowing right.
Those are my [inaudible] let me know my
death, my time, everything, or I have to,
to, to dive computers.
I check them. I look,
I calm, I checked my lad, I got to turn
my light and burn, burned my, uh, our,
um, pressure gauges, their
glow in the dark, right?
So I charged it with my light and I
look at, okay air, check my second one.
Okay air. I know my third one's good
because I haven't even opened it yet.
That's just, just in case I
breathe down, I fucking think,
and I can't even see my
hands in front of me.
And to this day I closed my eyes and
it gives me nightmares. Write him out,
just thinking about it. Cloudy,
dark, can't see anything.
All I can see is the home of my light.
So I turned my light off.
I'm not trying to think of
like, all right, just, just,
just calm, calm yourself,
figure this out. Where's,
where's our partner?
I start feeling around and he's nowhere
to be found, right? Nowhere to be found.
So I'm now,
I've called myself a little bit and I
start feeling the walls and I start moving
around.
I'm trying to think where am I?
But I don't know because we
haven't been down this channel yet,
so I don't visually haven't made
an imprint of, oh there's that.
There's this right.
Kind of like a mental imprint in my mind.
Cause that's what we're doing as
we're coming in and landmarks, right?
I don't have any of those. I don't
have any field. I don't have any touch.
And I'm moving around,
moving around.
I took a compass reading of the direction
of the front when we tied up at the
first jump,
right?
So I know 126 degrees is the way out,
but in a cave they twist and they move
and they're up and they're big and
they're deep and they're low.
Right?
There's no rhyme or reason
how the water made the cave.
So it's kind of a
direction I can think of.
First thing that comes to my mind
and I start swinging that way. Now.
I hit a wall, boom, and I go down.
I hit a wall and I'm fucking in panic
mode again. I fucking swimming now.
I just start swimming and
kicking a fucking going crazy.
I make my way out of the silt and I
fucking turned on back on the main line,
right?
I find the main line to the cave again,
which is a hundred yards
to the front to the door
and grab a hold of the main line.
I fucking real it. Anyhow. Okay.
Now the entire behind me
deeper into the cave is free.
It's no problem. Silt free.
I can see everything's good.
We're I need to go is
fucking self out and blown.
Gone and completely fucking wash. I
can't, I couldn't see you sitting there,
but I can see everything
behind us to can't see you.
I have the main line, but I don't have
the jump line to get the fuck out.
So I started thinking,
I was looking in the cave maps to
try and like before we went in,
just to try to get a visualize
of, of, of the direction.
I'm trying to remember landmarks,
but I can't see anything and I can't feel,
and I'm like, fuck, there was a split
up here. So I start, uh, go back into,
back into the silt again.
And I started feeling around and I'm
feeling, and I find a hole. And I'm like,
is that the right way? Is that the one I
want to go down? Where does that one go?
Okay. Maybe remind, remember,
remember, remember? That's okay.
Let's go to this next one.
I go into the next one and now this is,
this is where it's gotta be.
I'm going,
but all of a sudden I'm
swimming against the current.
And I remember when I came into this cave,
there was this very slow current,
which is why the entire caves now
washed out from that point on, right?
The current is taking out. So I'm like,
fuck, you're swimming against the current,
so you're going the wrong way.
I somehow work that into
my fucking panic mind.
We're all swimming into the car.
We're swimming in the corner.
That's overall going the wrong way.
So I fucking turned swim back.
I'm back on the fucking main line again,
right? A find the main lines clear.
I out into the clear
main line. Fuck, fuck,
fuck. I start like hyperventilating
and panicking and I'm thinking, man,
are you fucking you piece of shit? This
is how he will die. What the fuck are you
right? Keep reminding, kissing
my wife and kid by kid saying,
I'm coming home today. I'm
coming home. I'm coming home.
So I'd do it again. I fucking venture
into the fucking great unknown.
Fucking a bis. Total blackout.
Another panic. Panic.
Fucking freak out.
Can't find a way hitting my head.
Chicken losing air by the fucking second,
Bro.
Cause now I'm breathing hard on breathing.
Fucking irrational and I'm sucking
my tank's dry right? Mind you,
I'm on air, so I don't have, there's
no, there's no answer to this.
After I breathe my last breath,
keep checking within.
Keep keeping my time. Look in direction.
Time, time, air, time, fuck slowdown.
Slowdown, slowdown diamond pitch,
fucking black. Can't see anything.
Trying to figure out where I'm at. What
I'm thinking, what am I doing? Okay,
we're running out of air. How much
time do we have? Kalbi war at 28 feet.
I know we're at 28 feet.
I could probably read on this for about
another hour on this tag. Another hours.
We've got another hour. Okay, we've
been in here fucking 38 minutes already.
How?
What are we going to do?
Start trying to find my way out.
I can't. Trying to find a way out.
I can't now. I started
thinking, what am I going to do?
I'm not going to drown Joe drownings
like my biggest fear of my life,
so it was a thing that's called
a BC and we carried on her bag.
It's a buoyancy control device.
That's how you,
that's how you control your buoyancy
when you're scuba diving, right.
It probably holds
20 big,
huge strong breasts, so I feel that
motherfucker up. This is my plan.
MOFILM IBC up, which throws me
to the top of the cave punk.
Right now.
I'm only now I got to flip upside down
and I have like crawl on the ceiling
trying to figure out where the fuck I am,
how I'm at now I've got to get out of
a cave upside down and I'm thinking,
all right,
we've switched to our last bit of air.
How are we going to do this, Calvin?
What are we going do? We filled RBC up.
When I run out of air, I'm now thinking
in my mind, how am I going to die, Joe,
right? Tell my wife, tell my kid I'm
not fucking, I'm coming home now.
I got to fucking realize
how am I going to die?
I have a notepad that you carry in
your pocket to draw on. Right on.
I'm thinking of what? What? What
are you going to say? What's your,
what's your letter going to be?
You're writing a fucking death later.
You're awake. You're a
fighter. We figured this out.
They will fucking find a way to Kuwait.
You fucking bitch.
He's the conversation I'm having with
myself while I'm in fucking bleed.
Panic morning, complete darkness, thinking
that there's no, this is how people die.
What the fuck are you doing?
You're going to write a letter to
your fucking kid and tell her how you,
how you fucked up. I'm sorry,
Daddy's not coming home.
So I'm fucking thinking
I'm not going to drown.
I'm not going to breathe my last breath.
So I'm to breed this BC that just fill
up with air and I'm a fucking breathe it
until the oxygen level no longer happens
and I'd just pass out. That's, that's my,
that's what I've come to
realize how I'm going to die.
I'm going to fucking just
slip away and pass out,
keep breathing the same air until
I go away and I start thinking,
you fucking piece of shit.
You're,
you're giving up.
I think you're having the legitimate
conversations with myself while fucking NP
complete panic. Like you're,
you're going to quit that.
You're writing a letter and you're gonna
fucking breathe your last air until you
pass out you fucking pussy. You're
a fighter. Figured the fuck out.
So I'm upside down and crawling on the
ceiling. And I remember when I came in,
we came in the big cave and as like a
huge fucking crack that runs along the top
turn both of my watches
off now at this point,
because they're giving off light
and I kill my light. I said,
that cracked going to
fucking lead to the surface.
That cracks going to fucking give us
something. So I just call start panicking.
Me Panicking again because I'm panicking.
I don't know what to do.
I'm sucking air and a fucking breathing
hard and I'm hyperventilating and crying
on the sitting,
crawling on the ceiling,
looking for this fucking crack
and God damn it, I found it.
I found the crack and I followed the crack
and the crack got bigger and all of a
sudden I see fucking glow. Like
green glow. Crawl on crawl cron.
Find it. Try to get up.
My tags are too big.
I can't fucking get out of the little
hole. Can't get out of the hole.
I'm fucking big, big,
big, big fucking hitting,
screaming, freaking out. Calm down, calm
down. Calm down, Kelly. This is the way,
calm the fuck down. Reel it in.
Reel it in. We're here. We made it
grab control,
fall the cracks and more opens up out,
boom. There's theK
fucking I'm out made it.
You're coming home. You
are Doug about. Wow.
That was the feeling.
Meanwhile, my guys out there,
I can't be mad at him because he panicked.
He grabbed the line,
he fucking ran out the hole.
He looks at me and he says,
MMM,
so we're not diving together ever
again. We, I said, no, that was it.
That was it. And I texted my
girl, I love you baby. And uh,
they was a fucking scary moment,
but daddy's coming home
and it was fucking so crazy
because that was, I mean,
I've almost died numerous times,
but almost dying slowly,
which puts it in perspective to me
like these guys on death row. What?
I always thought like, yeah,
fucking killer murderer man.
That's fuck him dude.
Knowing the time and how
much time you have left,
that's some scary shit, Joe. Knowing
that you have two hours left,
how much air do you have left at the end?
Maybe another hour.
Probably an hour and some change.
But
could you imagine how I had to talk
to myself, how I was going to die,
like to me that fuck me up.
Fuck me up really bad.
Like I probably had to go do some
costumes and ask myself two questions now
because that fucked me up bad.
But the inner me, the fighter,
the youth do new fare at the fuck out.
But was I going to write a letter? I was
fucking damn close to write in a letter.
It was crazy, man. It was wild.
Damn. Hold on. I explained that.
Good for everybody. You explained
it like a motherfucker. Yeah,
I'm nervous like I was there.
Fuck Dude.
That is crazy.
Yeah man.
And I'm going to do it again.
Like I'm not scared of it like that.
It's just needs to be done better.
I'll run my own motherfucking line.
It also shows you how important it is.
Like what your wife was saying,
you can camp. She, you know,
she, she knew something.
She had a sense like right when people
fuck up a lot or when they're just that
person that just can't keep it together.
You gotta be real careful around those
people. Yeah. Yeah. Fucking crazy shit,
man. I mean, that's why people
kill those people in war.
Yeah. You know, they just like, look,
we can't do this. Yeah. We can't.
Everybody killed. Yeah. Your, your,
your panic is sure. Yeah, sure.
Yeah. You're not hanging in there.
You, you've become a detriment.
Fuck Dude. That is one of the craziest
stories I've ever heard in my life,
but I'm glad I got to share it with you.
Fucking impressive.